[Music]
like I do
okay wedding we should have once a month
all girls Jake am saying
you hear that job
we caught you Joe let's tell me all
you'd ask okay I'm glad I asked
I'm with you do you guys don't bequest
us to never done in my life oh no she
doesn't leave a girl hanging
oh wait I'm confused huh oh she doesn't
their face you might ask - she's like
huh a man who was dumped 48 years ago
still hasn't opened a gift he held on to
from his ex that's me on the petty scale
I give this a 6 yeah yeah why why why my
wife for 48 years
well why does it even matter maybe it
was just like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
there is some Eminem songs I haven't
listened to just in case
like if something happens to him like I
have some songs left to listen to oh
that's so cute that's actually really
cute thank you that's adorable I don't
want anything to happen to him but
what's the real meaning behind adorable
though what can you see that the door
I'm cute Gio get over it you that's
action you superhero I have something
new to listen to all the time I free
dice this story is about Adrian who's 65
years old from Canada he when he was 17
he had this girlfriend named Vicki who
was 15
sounds like hope she's 15 oh [ __ ] sorry
fifteen year old Vicki here so back in
1970 Vicki gave him a present and then
immediately dump to death
oh he walked home and that he was really
upset and angry because it was around
Christmas time he ended up just putting
the Christmas or the Christmas present
under the Christmas tree and he left it
there and so Christmas morning everyone
opened up all their presents but then
like he decided not to open that present
he's like I vowed to never ever open
this present because a part of him
wanted to keep keep it and hope that
they would get back together and that
they could open it together but then
they just never happened and so he held
on to this Christmas present he
eventually got married and had kids in
every single year for like 20 years he
would put that Christmas gift under the
tree and the wife was a salt chilli I'd
be like honey what's that yeah
no hurry ends here that [ __ ] in the fire
mommy you not run so ok so then the wife
was like alright fine you have your
little present whatever but then I got
to the point when his daughter who was
like about five years old they she asked
like can I open this he was like no and
then like the kids just kept wondering
like why can't we ever open this present
because he still wants to get back
together yeah I like that
in other news husband gets shot by what
exact the next day I want her name and
social security number if it's her if I
was her I'd be like maybe we should
discuss this before we got married I
feel like this is something we should
have discussed hmm
yeah cuz it's been something that he's
been doing since he was 17 so then after
like 20 years the wife put her foot down
it was like alright you can still keep
this dude wait a minute after 20 years
you're not putting your [ __ ] foot
down okay that's what it's called it's
called she's finally speaking up who did
it in the bud now it's a whole rosebush
and you're like no roses garden at this
point it was like 20 years of him doing
it not necessarily 20 years of their
marital anyway okay so she finally put
her foot down she was like you keep the
present but don't put it under the
Christmas tree anymore because it's
weird [ __ ] really my Christmas every
year imagine something [ __ ] about filled
with her [ __ ] shitty ass wrapping her
cheap-ass tape just like something [ __ ]
out of yeah
yeah so then so he says that he will
take it out every time he's roughing
every year he's wrapping Christmas
presents just to look at it and then put
it away that's weird man Christmas is
you me and the family not you me the
family and your ex-girlfriend from 1970s
so imagine right
imagine hear me out here it was a
pregnancy test and she said if you want
to be in the baby's life call me when
you get home Lifetime movie I want to
watch this movie so he didn't know cuz
he never opened it yeah never called so
now she's out there with a baby [ __ ] so
now he has a 50 year-old son it's like
those Chicken Soup for the Soul stories
did you ever read those and then the one
like when what I haven't heard that in
so long
oh the Graduate like the kid graduated
and he wanted a car and then and then he
got like a Bible for his graduation he
was like passed and he liked the Bible
whatever and then like years later he
opened the Bible and there was a check
for the amount that the car was from his
debt for his parents and he never he
hadn't talked to his parents cat [ __ ]
anymore no no any any like they ruins
their relationship he never talks to his
parents again and then and they were
dead or whatever I forget what how the
story was but like it was so sad that
sucks
see see it could have been a pregnancy
that's a that's a good story do they end
up opening it well so T first of you
still is Adrienne bro you gotta stop
living in the past what a nice beard oh
wow nice photo a gym membership he's
like it's a new me you were right about
her city rats got a piece of the tape on
the left some video game
no so he said that some of the tape
doesn't really fully seal because there
was a one moment of weakness also he
peeps he kind of like she um peeled it
but he stopped himself but so like that
one piece of tape or whatever it doesn't
work so then it looks like a VHS this is
Vickie 1515 why do I look 40 you know he
stalks her Facebook all right yeah she's
doing the thing is that he doesn't it
did it it wasn't about her anymore it
just turned into like this tradition of
his and like kinda a weird yeah it kind
of turned into this thing where it's
like he kind of has to always keep it
like he loves not knowing what's inside
harmless but weird he's lucky he's not
with me cuz I would have gotten that
[ __ ] the first [ __ ] Christmas I give
me that mother [ __ ] opened up here
don't actually the [ __ ] is this what you
want that's what you want huh [ __ ]
rub it in his face
yeah by Christmas I would have bought
some nice boots with a long heel and I
would have long heel yeah nice little
sled oh and just pierced right through
the middle of it yeah so he even wrote a
book about all this 47 year old present
oh and it looks like the present the
book looks like the rabid ghoul
I didn't even notice especially really
neat oh and it's the picture what if you
make some money off fair that's plain
she came back she's like you know what
it was my present I won't pour that
money to huh yeah so he was searching
for her for a while cuz this whole story
like first one viral last year but then
the reason why were talking about it now
is because they he finally found Vicki
there were a lot of Impostors pretending
to be here but he finally found the real
big but now like Vicki and his wife are
like close friends like they talk to
each other when he's not around and [ __ ]
this is not the movie I signed up I
apologize on the half
so you guys hear that they're Canadian
kind of white people all of us just all
red and we were like yeah it's like
those riddles where they're like you're
the bus driver you pick up to people and
then you let off three and then you let
pick up five more and then who's the bus
drivers [ __ ] I don't know and it's like
I said at the beginning
[Laughter]
who's driving the bus yeah so then
finally like now that he's communicated
with a gig and he's decided because he
has gone through a lot of health issues
throughout his life like he cancer at
one point because he's holding on to the
[ __ ] path yeah that's right oh so
because of all that he decided well like
you know what right now I'm in good
health she's in good health we should
get together open it together with it so
they're actually opening it this year
and they're gonna charge for people to
see that imagine how big she feels
knowing that her 15 year old aunts got
him a gumball and he's about to open it
after all these years and she doesn't
remember either that's her she's like
yeah let's do it
I'll keep she doesn't remember she does
it it doesn't remember what the what it
is something spiteful because she gave
it to him and then broke up with him
yeah so they're selling tickets to the
event but then the money's gonna be
going to a Christmas Bureau so what's a
Christmas bureau's Canadian the
Christmas [ __ ] ice skating Bureau I
think my assumption is where they give
presents to people they need wow that's
pretty cool okay cuz I was gonna say
imagine being a bad in the holidays
happen for deserving families oh that's
awesome better Hey are you laughing for
the wife is like thank God it's over
dude I I would not I would not be and
then also when he's like like imagine
your husband coming downstairs me like
Martha I found Vicki I'm like oh you did
it
that's funny cuz I found her last week
and I don't thank you over remediate all
the years were good there oh yeah it
doesn't even matter he's obsessed with
her out you're out even if it was when
he was 15 but if he's still obsessed
with her he gets all giddy taking out
this gift every year adding all the
giddy [ __ ]
no he's she said it in the article but
he he takes it out over here it's a
tradition to him and get excited about
it you can't get excited about you're
supposed to love me yeah get about me
and this I'm the exciting part of this
relationship what if he what if he meets
her and then she became like this like
this this like super butch biker he's
just like oh not mine he just he just
romanticizes his own story he just like
jerks off to it that's part of this
vision every year take out this old box
right after no not November
Thank You December it goes other
packages like well it's December first
Mac box used to be white and then I'm
crusted over
[Music]